sir been watching this prey is paranoid
about standing up in front of their
classroom and eighth grade having give a
speech right so now imagine sitting in
front of GM's and head coaches in the
NFL and you're being just grilled on
questions that Santa felt online we want
to create a version of that we hear it
we say it we believe it but can we see
the effect
and games online you can see in a
person's eyes it's noticeable the effect
they make the players around them better
be effective welcome to the in factory
adding the NFL Combine style interview
this year was great in terms of getting
to know these kids what makes them tick
seeing their confidence level and it's
another uncomfortable setting it's a
constant stream of questioning for eight
minutes expecting them to be able to
handle another stressful anxiety ridden
environment you can just tell by how
much is he sweating what he's doing his
fingers how uncomfortable is he going in
I was pretty nervous hi I had no idea
what to expect I never been inside of an
NFL Combine room or anything like that
what is one thing that if you could
you'd like to change about yourself I'm
constantly like you said even though I'm
not supposed to do I'm constantly
fighting with myself so mentally I judge
myself the hardest I'm hardest on myself
and I wish I wish somebody to work on
going for it is to not be so hard on
myself if I mess up you're over you know
and go into the next place keep in mind
that they're still figuring out who they
are they're still figuring out the game
they're still figuring out what is
appropriate as a response
you're gonna hit adversity and you just
have to kind of embrace it before I'll
just kind of let it get me down but then
I realized it's a part of it you have to
welcome it you have to overcome
he answered that question like with an
answer like that like yeah that's a pro
answer yeah well then this is a great
training ground to be bold to be clear
and to learn around people that want to
help it's good to be a letter size I
mean it's really a lot I don't leaven in
a row either comma
he'll happen to be sit there all the guy
who's just taken number one overall in
the draft Jared Goff and by the way he's
grilling them on these questions there's
so many people in there you're not
roaming your eyes around the room you're
making eye contact answering your
question next question I look over and
it's Jared Goff I'm like you're in a bus
with a bunch of people going down a
windy road snowy and the bus loses its
brakes we're on the bus you want to be
sitting probably driver's seat cuz
you're the person who can solve the
problem be in control I guess I was a
pretty good answer and he laughed and I
said it and shake I said like he might
answer the same question or somebody
might ask him that when he has gone
through the process so this was the
question I was actually asked about what
two months ago being able to look back
on that something that bankfull I went
through and I think it's the ability to
react in a situation that you really
haven't prepared for do you ever get
tired of people asking you about your
family sometimes yeah definitely I mean
I love it that I love them so it's not a
super big deal I know they get it too so
it's not something I hate but sometimes
I just win it Oh only when someone over
does it it gets a little boy what's your
favorite part of this whole process what
are you trying to get out of it I just
want to get better I want to get better
for myself and for my team because like
coach Dover said it's not about you it's
about making other people around you
better when you talk about making people
better you went through some adversity
four years ago you became the man in the
house how is that helped you on your
journey as a leader you know the first
six months after my dad passed away I
was an auto leader Sam loses his dad
when he's 13
the moment I thought I will never see my
dad again
I automatically dropped my body just
gave out and ever since that time it's
kind of been a process to learn Who I am
the worst part of them losing their dad
was to watch them be sad it was really
really hard and we still missin of
course do you embrace that pain I do
talk about your dad you still look at
pictures of them you have the memories
or have you kind of packed it away and
you just don't want to deal with it
most days I probably do push it away I
kind of look past it when I lost him I
was torn inside I had no reason to be in
this world I hated everything I hated
life he was my best friend he taught me
everything and then I realized I can't
live my life like this and I'm gonna
have to get over it eventually and so we
were from then on I realized that my
family's feeling the same way and I'm
gonna pull him out of that the only way
that my brother and sister my mom are
gonna succeed if there is that stability
and I want to be that rock that keeps
them together and makes them move in a
positive direction so mom how do you
think I've done taking care of Jake and
Morgan in our family I think you find me
he has been the rock for all of us and
of course I try not to you know put that
kind of pressure on him she want a kid
to be a kid hey
I was volleyball good he just has a
strength about him and an attitude if
everything's gonna be okay he's an
amazing kid he really is with the given
situation that I've had it's not just
learning how to deal with yourself it's
learning how to do with life because
I've been through the worst of the worst
that's one of the worst things that you
can ever go through and knowing that I
can get through that in a positive way
that gave me confidence to know that I
can do that with whoever it is in
whatever situation right great it makes
me that's awesome thanks so much thanks
for answering hard stuff yes sir that's
hard stuff man thank you it makes a
lesson for all of us that when life gets
hard and throws those things that were
not prepared for embrace him and always
look at the positive thank you Joey
robbers came up with a great idea for
the combine interviews he's like let's
have one question that we asked all the
kids and let's let's find a question
that kind of digs into their psyche a
little bit and where they kind of feel
like the pecking order is if you were
starting a program right now and you
cannot choose yourself as a starting
quarterback which of these starting
quarterbacks would you choose Alex you
hunter Jonathan hunter on earth probably
hunter Honda throws a pretty ball and I
think that dad stood hundred Johnson why
that kick it flat-out ball you're not
the first yesterday
Hunter Johnson that's the one guy that I
think even though I know he wasn't there
with us this morning and stuff like that
but that dude he's a baller you know I
have so much respect for him out of the
24 kids Hunter Johnson was the
predominant answer
coming into everything I was like oh man
it's gonna be a big weekend just gotta
get through it but I feel like I was
able to to really focus football when I
was doing football and then once I got
to the track and ended up running pretty
well
for Hunter Johnson to come out a day
early get his Saturday combines
workout in on Thursday so that's a guy
who throw again on Friday with all the
kids when they get here and then get on
a red-eye flight Friday night from Los
Angeles California
fly across the country to Indianapolis
Indiana and running the state track meet
you don't see that and to have that
overwhelming response from his peers
after only being with them for half of
the first two days was it was very
impressive just landed in LA again glad
to be back at the field right now ready
to compete it's easy to relate to all
these guys because they're you know I'll
talk to your guys and we all handle the
same stuff so I hope they think I'm a
person that's easy to be around you know
I like to think of myself as a humble
person and let my my play do the talk we
spoke to a couple folks at your high
school okay and one of them told us that
you had a problem stealing stealing yeah
really yeah we wanted to see how kids
would respond if we mess with them a
little bit and shot discs ready didn't
freak out steal honest with you we had
some fun with them we didn't do that to
everybody there's certain kids you know
you can Shawn's obviously kid loves that
fun so it's good timing by dr. Travelle
yeah good job Shawn for the most part
kids killed it let's take Mack Jones for
instance what company would you want to
be the CEO of I don't want to be an
inheritor or of a big company I just
kind of wanna make my own idea I don't
like to follow people you follow you get
stomped on that's my motto so so there
are certain guys gotta flip the script
- I'm six four I mean you drop back same
offensive line do you think we can see
the same I mean if the blonde six-foot
then you'd probably see better but the
lines know me six five so probably see
the same I totally agree with you it was
definitely one of the better things
we've done because we got to know him
that we hadn't before you have to pick
one or the other what is better
competing or winning competing Tom's
just a winner you know losing is not in
my DNA Mouse
yeah sundown bud not a lot of people
know his story he's overcome a lot you
know his family was relocated after
Hurricane Katrina Hurricane Katrina was
something uh none of us expected no my
parents told us to pack a few pairs of
clothes and we'll be back um 12 weeks
later come back to a lot full of sand
you know lost a house lost all the
childhood pictures and everything you
know the whole nine yards moved down to
a Fort Lauderdale Florida and bought a
boat Gina restart talking about
personalized emotions gonna take it over
here oh I can't oh I just got kind of
tough
my dad was commuting to New Orleans you
know every week you know that's where
his job was upstairs loading my mom
taking care of three boys at the time
you know it was a difficult time
I knew miles really worked through some
emotional difficult times one of the
very first things he came to his mom and
I said getting me on a football team and
once we did get him onto football teams
and kind of started living a little bit
more of a normal life at that time they
were in paradise we lived there for
three years you know by the best three
years of my life you know just special
moments you know most families would
stay together my mom dad have been
married 36 years and until a lot of ups
and downs obviously I want to get the
NFL but you know to provide for the
family that I will have you know that's
my main goal once I realized that
nothing can stop me the thing that we've
learned about miles is his competitive
nature is second to none
intense jaw clenched miles Brennan
promised us I will make the 11 you know
I've kind of been the underdog
throughout this whole recruiting process
in general um I come here same thing
type of deal we know it fires me up you
know I'm going to earn that that spot in
Oregon I can prom
drop the mic and walked out there's so
much fire in this I feel it a little
hair Stolp on my arms when he walked out
of the room I'm like yeah that guy could
leave my team
I love like learning new things like
like the state fish of a fish a quiet
which is the home of who we know can do
got water siddhis yep absolutely
Oh gun show
Justin Holly you did didn't you funk out
her Greek I should have known